les sorcières de salem une histoire de
sorcellerie de psychose collective et de
marginalité
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le village de salem au
massachusetts
à la fin du xviie siècle dans une très
petite communauté puritaine très
croyante qui va à l'église qui entend
parler constamment du démon des
pratiques de sorcellerie qui nuit il en
faut bien être des communautés et à
l'harmonie depuis trois ans un nouveau
ministre du culte est arrivé à salem il
s'appelle samuel par isl est arrivé avec
sa fille betty avec son épouse mais
aussi avec une servante de la barbade du
nom de tissus bas à la peau noire qui
portent des vêtements étranger à cette
communauté puritaine de nouvelle
angleterre
betty la fille du ministre samuel paris
comment cette prise parfois de
tremblements elle se fige et se pétrifie
elle tombe au sol et les prises de
convulsions et on commence à se demander
qu'est ce qui se passe et elle affirme
qu'elle est en fait en sursaut les
quelqu'un l'a ensorcelé graduellement
d'autres passages d'autres jeunes filles
spontanément à l'église ou dans les rues
commencent à se pétrifier à tomber par
terre avec prise de convulsions une
forme de psychose collective se met en
place dans la communauté de célèbres
mousse et très probablement par la
sortie en fait d'un manuel que la
communauté lille publié par claude
marquis explique comment reconnaître des
actes de sorcellerie
comment une sorcière peut agir en fait
sur l'esprit des gens alors à partir du
mois de février 1692 lorsque les
premiers symptômes apparaissent chez
betty et ses amis nous allons essayer de
retrouver à salem qui pourrait être une
sorcière être alors betty sera interrogé
par les magistrats qui vont se présenter
pour déclencher une série de procès elle
va affirmer connaître en fait les
sorcières qui l'on en sort celui qui
sont responsables de sa stupéfaction
elle nomme tituba la servante de son
père elle nomme aussi une mendiante le
nom de sarah good et elle nomme une
vieille femme qui vit en marge de sa
communauté dans les bois et qui
travaille beaucoup avec les plantes qui
ne voit plus à l'église sera au second
très rapidement on va donc étudier les
cas de salem comme étant un code
sorcellerie est de plus en plus de cas
vont se manifester entre février 1892 et
le mois de mai 1793 ce sont dix neuf
hommes et femmes qui seront accusés de
sorcellerie et qu'ils seront condamnés à
la pendaison
et c'est ce qui explique que les procès
de salem soit si populaire aujourd'hui
bien entendu c'était une fausse nouvelle
des jeunes filles qui se sont inventé
des histoires pour pouvoir se divertir
mais les gens vont attraper cette fausse
nouvelle
la développer en rumeur ils vont en
profiter pour l'utiliser comme une arme
afin de se débarrasser des gens qui le
détestent ou des gens dont ils on perd
souvent ceux et celles qui sont en marge
de leur commune
[Musique]